over dollar thresholds which vary a
little bit but um
make sure that the money's there make
sure that the the paperwork is all done
make sure that there is a
there's a paper trail for transactions
that there's a that they're
pre-audited of most transactions this is
an important piece of the fiscal control
of the state
it is the fiscal control agency of the
state
as part of the capital budget there's a
capital budget request which is
fairly firmly ensconced in the capital
budget and very high on
dennis goulet's ranking of i.t projects
and that so that
um even if it fell off it would be it
would be done which is moving to the
it's listed as moving to the cloud we
take the state's enterprise software
system and move it to the cloud
it's much more complicated than that
it's a very significant upgrade
and as part of that we would move to a
cloud-based service instead of a instead
of a
you know land-based service if you will
um but it would be
the most significant financial upgrade
to the state in
probably a dozen years and we'll talk
about that when we talk about fdm
but included here are three positions
one in the commissioner's office
one in the accounting services office
and one in fdm
but i've bundled them together because
they are part of
the financial systems upgrade this will
be
enormously complicated will affect every
agency around the state
and these are the positions are all
business systems analysts or
in the case of fdm and information
systems analyst and it would be part of
that
massive undertaking would you need these
ongoing year after year even after the
upgrade so we
we would because um for example the fdm
position would continue to do
the the regular upgrades the state's
financial systems got in trouble over
decades when we stopped upgrading and we
you know ended up having and i know you
know this i'm not sure everybody's aware
of the
the history where um we had a financial
system that was
you know put in place in 1983 and then
we kind of didn't upgrade it very much
it'd be like if you were using
wordperfect instead of or
in wordperfect3 with dual disk drive and
that was kind of where we were
as a state we need to upgrade
continually in an ongoing basis
or else we end up having a system that's
defunct and dead
and we end up spending 20 30 40 million
dollars to get a new system
that's part of what this is the the
position in accounting services would to
be honest once this project was done
which is a multi-year project would move
into the fixed asset module
and would uh and would um would perform
that function there
so that um they would be on an ongoing
basis
but slightly repurposed
what happens if you don't get these
um well we're gonna upgrade the system
anyway it just becomes enormously
difficult
um it becomes
um i i don't want to say it becomes a
complete nightmare to do
people might know that when we did the
original erp
the system that's now in for um 10
12 years ago we basically asked people
to do
well i'm going to point at joe joe
bouchard did
the upgrade from nine to five
and then came back to the office at
about 4 30
and did his regular job of assistant
commissioner
and it damn near killed him one of your
assistant commissioners i'm not sure if
it's cassie or joe since they're
together would also like to say
something on this topic
cassie is it you or joe who wishes to
speak um
it's me please i would just like to
point out that the very last slide
on the back of your slide deck has all
the detail about the bundles and the
specific positions in their funding
thank you cassie thank you so i have the
same
question here sarah does this include
all those costs and if not what would
those be
and you're going to have to for every
one of these will you just say to
yourself i'll figure that out and get it
over to them
yes thank you charlie please continue
um thank you for that um so that's
accounting services broadly speaking
um what i want to do is i'm going to ask
cassie if she would talk a little bit
about the division of personnel
this is my attempt to make sure that our
presentation is not
completely boring and that i'm doing all
of the talking but
um she'll talk about the current
pressure that division of personnel is
under
on slide six good morning
good morning um we have a central
personnel office it's called the
division of personnel
and they support some central functions
including recruitment hiring and
training
it also includes our employee relations
office and they uh
they negotiate with our employee unions
and now uh we're up to 11
unions and we run a self-funded bureau
of education and training
and i think there's two significant
things i would like to say about
um the division of personnel one is
is that um when commissioner arlinghaus
joined us uh he had direction from the
governor that we needed to
modernize our personnel system and um
we concur with that 100 and so we have
been working very hard
to develop central policies when
appropriate
and to support flexibility and speed so
that the agencies who are conducting the
business of state government
have their personnel needs met as
quickly as possible
what's happened to the division of
personnel over the last
two years is so they've undergone a lot
of change they've had turnover in staff
they've had retirements and
um when the when the budget that we're
currently in
was passed um we had a very significant
lapse requirement and then
what happened i i believe it's just a
matter of timing they had vacancies that
came across
came along because of retirement people
switching jobs
and they were very very detrimental to
them
not only doing their day-to-day business
but doing the personnel system reform
that
we believe is necessary so when you look
at this slide we have
um we have bundle number two which
includes
three full-time positions in one one um
one part-time position and these
positions
are critical to deliver
hr services to our agencies with the
speed that they need to recruit to
retain
to manage their employees and to also do
that reform work that we talked about
in this budget um by the way we have
completely converted the bureau of
education and training
to a um income-based model
so there are no general funds supporting
the bureau of education
um and that's a departure from the
current budget
so i think that um some
summer summarizes the uh division of
personnel
two other things i would i want to point
out uh because people will remember this
uh first of all transitioning bet to a
to a tuition-based model
instead of general fund supported when
it used to be roughly 50 50
is no small accomplishment and i want to
um
and and i say that having had nothing to
do with it myself that
the people who work for us um did a
really good job on it
and um and it was hard it was difficult
particularly in this climate
um that we're in but it's a it's a big
thing and it's a direction we could
receive from the governor's office
um there are two other pieces people
remember the last budget we were
required to do
by house bill 2 house before i guess um
a personnel report on on modernizing the
system reforming the system
um because it people know that the
system itself
is an enormous source of frustration to
uh
agencies the thing i hear most from
other commissioners about are personnel
matters
and i don't mean discipline i mean uh
can i re-class
how does this can we is this possible
what is the rule for
and it's complicated and our the idea is
to make it more modern and functional
um we did a report on that that which
came out probably a year ago at this
point
um the second thing is in that budget
was a comp study
um we did an initial small version for
troopers because of a a second special
language in the
in the um in house bill 4 i think as
well
but one of the things house bill 4
called for was a
study of the state's system of
compensation and total compensation
uh with comparators to private and
public sector that report was placed on
hold during the
um early stages of the pandemic for well
for
for quite some time because frankly if
we were in a climate where we were going
to have to lose
you know 10 to 15 percent of the state
budget it was an area that was probably
going to
not happen because it was you know
something we weren't doing today we
wouldn't have to do
um when that seemed like it was not
going to be the case when some of the
spending
restraints were lifted we we did it not
because we
we thought it was a good idea or a bad
idea but we did it because we're
required to do it by house bill 4. that
will probably be released i know i saw a
draft
um early this week or late last week i
don't know recently
and that will probably be released in
short order and i know that's something
that
the this committee talked about two
years ago as well
so i want you to know that that's out
there
so charlie i have two questions and one
the report
how did you guys account for in the
report some of our positions are 37.5
hours a week as opposed to private
industry which is
40 hours a week so when you're doing a
salary comparison how did you
work that out well you can um you know
we
obviously we heard a consultant who does
a lot of comp studies and a lot of
public sector comp studies
um on this and it's um uh
you just you just um make an allowance
for that that it's
you know 37 and a half is 37.5 divided
by 40 of
40 hours and that's the easiest way to
do that um
there are intangibles in any sort of
compensation system where you look at
things and you say
you know are you putting a premium what
premium are you putting on on
you know this perk or this benefit all
we can really do
is look at uh you know convert things to
an hourly compensation rate look at what
benefits are
look at you know for example if you work
for the state
you get on average um
[Music]
i don't remember the number anymore 15
to 20 more days off
than you do if you work in the in the
private sector they're also comparators
to
to state and local government or to
local government
um that's not necessarily something you
can account for financially so
a lot of things you can you can attach a
financial number to some things though
are intangible and so there's a
qualitative as opposed to quantitative
component to the report as well i think
all right second question
bundle two all general fund positions i
know this is um
you just talked about this as a mixture
of income based plus
general funds no it's all general fund
all your fun thank you
please continue unless somebody has a
question right now i don't see any
others you're doing good
oh i should look at the screen you're
not being lectured you're not being
chastised then you can answer all the
questions see
i'm eat i'm i'm eager to be lectured and
chastised when i need to be though
just for the record um
okay thank you um and i would point out
that there are page numbers at the top
of each slide there are the page numbers
in the budget
that correspond to this if you want to
look at specific accounting units
when i say that thank you i say that
because plant and property is about to
come up
which has more accounting units than a
than a horse
we manage buildings we manage four
million square feet of office space we
manage something like 90 buildings
depending on what you count as a
building and
uh and then a bunch of leased space as
well
um particularly in the bureau of court
facilities
um courts are done sort of separately
from everything else but
um this particular division
um includes a great deal of transfers
from other agencies so
so we do the work uh the money's in our
budget but it's also transferred from
from other agencies i will tell you that
um
that uh i i had a i had a meeting with
with uh with matt mayo the the the
governor's new budget director
the one of those things about you know
what do you have any pieces of advice to
give him and what little advice i could
give
i said if you're going to build a budget
there are two things you have to do at
the beginning of the budget process
if you're building a statewide budget
one is settle doit
because they affect every other agency's
budget lines yeah we didn't get that
done very well
well we're working on it there's some
work i haven't told don't
don't preview anything i haven't told
joe yet okay
the uh and the other thing is plant and
property because the other thing that
affects a lot of agency budgets is the
plant and property number
there's a number in their budget there's
a number in our budget it's
it's double counting but it's double
counting because it's it's accounting
for the cost to that agency
and then the money being spent here by
the people who do the work
that's why you see this as general funds
and other funds in the chart
on slide seven shows a significant
transfer from other agencies
some of those transfers come as general
funds
for example the courts entirely
other funds in our budget entirely
general funds in their budget
um so that's there so on this page
fiscal year 22 and fiscal year 23
are basically flat funded when compared
with adjusted authorized for fiscal year
21.
you have enough you believe you have
enough to do what you have to do to
maintain with that flock funding
yeah ish um now we ask the tough
question
it's um so
um the way we manage property in the
state of new hampshire is an
ongoing base but if you doubled the
budget we would spend the money
it's um you know you you walk around the
buildings of the state and there are
some buildings that are
um um
a or b buildings if you will um i met uh
karen rantamaki is the director of
planet property now when she was deputy
and steve laurenson was here
i sat down with them once and i said
before steve leaves
because he can do this because he's
leaving um do me a favor go through our
buildings
say what's an a what's a b what's a c
what's a d we didn't we decided nothing
was an f
and i think that was probably right um
just
generally and we you know we had two
buildings there i think that were a's or
maybe three
um and there are a lot of buildings that
are b's and c's and so what you do is
you look around and you go okay we can't
well we could fix that and i don't know
that's not critical and that's like well
the carpeting how's the carpeting look
it's a little threadbare but there are
no tripping hazards okay
and so everything we do is uh it's
actually not a bad
analogy for the rest of what we do as an
agency um
you fix the tripping hazards first and
you don't worry as much about what's
threadbare as long as it's functional
and so you know we have a deferred
maintenance list
that um i have one sitting on the corner
of my desk
i don't have the i want it's about a
year old but it was
basically uh maintenance staff walking
around all the buildings
with with an ipad like writing stuff
down and they wrote most of the things
down
it's not a hundred percent correct
because
if you've got a deferred maintenance
list that would cost about 100 million
dollars to fix
and you know you're going to fix about 2
million of it next year
you just got to get the big stuff on the
list and and that's what we do
and i think i think most buildings and
the maintenance fund two years ago was a
huge step in this direction to fix
the things that are most needy as
opposed to in the accounting units that
have money
we have enough money to take care of the
buildings in a big way presumably we can
we can hire in the current climate
um uh workers at a number of levels um
but we have enough money to do a decent
job not a
not a great job and and it's you know
it's the state of new hampshire you have
i don't need to tell you this but you
have eight million priorities that are
coming to you
and you're not going to be able to fund
half of them and
and that's the way it is so this is a
decent number i
i think plant and property was um um
is is reasonably adequately staffed at
this number
okay that's good to know um
so on the other hand if you got
some money you're not sure what to do
with uh yeah i can fix some stuff
we need to cut 79 million don't okay
um i would not cut 79 million out of
here that's all i'm saying
um if you want to turn to page two of or
the second
plan property slide which is slide eight
in your deck
if you will um
i talk about a couple of house bill two
provisions here
um that are probably gonna require at
least a little bit of discussion
the steam heating account is just
updating those numbers
people will remember that when concord's
team closed and we did a massive project
to convert
to convert a bunch of buildings i think
it was 40 separate projects
or something like that it's just it's
just finishing up but one of the
requirements of that is the seven
million dollars in
20 million dollars was taken out of
operating costs um
in a bill in i'm gonna say roughly march
of 2017
and about seven million dollars was
bonded and the requirement was that the
savings are used to pay for the so we
budget
the steem portion of class 23
at farewell correct me when i say
something stupid that's why she's here
i'm hoping that i don't say as many
stupid things okay
we budget uh the steam portion of class
23 at the number it would have been
and the money that we're spending which
is less than that we
used to pay off the debt service it's
transferred to what's called
the state heating system steam account
which is so we're talking about for
people who are looking at their hb2 at
home
we're talking about section two which
starts at the bottom of page one
and continues on to page two
and that you basically are asking us in
this section
to extend um
extend the timeline shall be non-lapsing
appropriated to the department of admin
services for the biennium
ending june 30th 2021 and the fiscal
year ending
june 30th 2022.
the money is then set in an account and
it's available for the treasurer to use
at the time they deem
necessary based on when they issue bonds
to pay off the bonds
uh representative burge thank you for
your presentation
just a question on on this page
uh you mentioned uh sheriff custody what
is that
oh that's the next thing i was going to
talk about and so if you look in
hb2 again you're now looking at
section 1 which is on top of the
steam section so you're on the same page
if you open your hb2
you got yours and you can see so charlie
go ahead
so um sheriff sheriff custody
reimbursements
um and i'm not going to say um as much
on this because i think
representative ober knows a lot more
about it than i do but
um we pay for for
um sheriff custody of prisoners we
reimburse
there's no reason this is in our budget
except that it has to be somewhere
and we don't have any control over it
and we don't we don't manage
it per se because we don't do the
custody
but there are so there are costs we
budget a number every year
the legislature the state budgets a
number every year
and um and it's never quite as much as
the
costs um and so what we did with this
line
we budgeted a number that's you know our
budget went down 15
so this number went down 15 that's it no
no real thought process in that and
except just lowering
it and then we were talking about it and
i said we should
have some sort of a you know this
shouldn't be first come first served
right that
we just have a have a run to the finish
line and and
you get your request in first you get
the money and then suddenly we're out
and nobody gets any more
so uh i came up with a formula based on
simplicity
it did not anything complicated more
complicated than that and said all right
every county
gets reimbursements let's decide that
you know if you're three percent of the
population of the state you get three
percent of
whatever money ends up being
appropriated and
uh you know the same process you got to
get you got to go through you got to get
reimbursed you got to do the work but
that's the cap when you hit that number
you're done and that's just
and i picked population because it was
it's an available statistic
i'm not wedded to it yes you have more
questions yeah follow-up uh i mean that
seems to work in theory but
i live in colorado county the largest
county in the state
it doesn't work for kawasaki you know
we're always short
i think so right now everybody's always
short
right that's uh because the the amount
appropriated is not as much as is spent
and the question is i think the question
is how do we
how do i phrase this how do we short
people equitably
um maybe population isn't the right
frayed but if we're going to short
everybody what's the
what's the best mechanism for prorating
road mileage might be a thing i don't
know
i don't think counties track that
it it is although i to be honest i'm not
exactly sure how you would
like what road mileage from where to
where
i mean i'm not by the way i'm not well
no we can we can debate this by road
knowledge i mean if
the number of roads that you have in
your county
uh we have uh i mean coast county is not
noted for
its um you know super highways no that's
right we talked about that
um class one two three four five and six
so more five and six than other counties
do
so i'm okay uh personally with anything
anything you come up no that that makes
sense based on the
i think it's something where i would i
would turn to
the legislature because you are the
county delegations
um to come up with what you think and
you have a much better idea how it
works which which
metrics if you will uh approximate your
operating costs
and we put in uh population as a
placeholder so
i have no what's the right phrase i have
no dog in this fight
i know in coast county large county has
roughly 31 000 people
oh i see and so you're saying your costs
because of the distance they have to
travel is higher
but your population is smaller that's
that
that's a fair point okay thank you yeah
but i'd support whatever you think is
fair you'll have to come up with a
suggestion
that's what he's saying he's given it
the best shot
legislature needs to work on i got that
loud and clear
okay are you looking for suggestions and
those are
anything well at this point all i'm
saying is that if you're gonna
if we're gonna appropriate a number
that's going to be less than is spent
we should have some mechanism for for
for deciding
how much everybody gets relative to
birds those are actually
lines 22 through 28 on page one
and it's no longer in his hands it's in
our hands
we would have to if we're going to amend
that
and commissioner arlen house has done
the best he can but now he's out of the
so he's explaining he's telling you he's
hearing what you're saying
but it's us
no no that's fine um
okay that's plantar property um any
other
plant property i should look at the
computer in front of me
okay representative leishman
good morning charlie hi you had a fairly
aggressive program over at the
gallon park last couple years as far as
rehabbing buildings
are you still rehabbing any buildings or
everything
kind of done over there i i think
everything isn't done so people will
know that if you think of the gallon
office park
or the sops camp as we call it sometimes
there is
a 2005-ish
master plan for the site which is sort
of being followed
there is a there's sort of a continual
effort to fix
bits of the inside of buildings and to
rehab some uh major buildings we
i think right now the biggest projects
on the capital budget list
are preserving um
[Music]
not phil brook the victorian building
next to the main building
i can't remember its name i do this all
the time i always want to say phil brook
and it's not
um but uh we're we're preserving that
building that that giant victorian
building right there
um from the weather um there are some
internal things happening in maine
building
but they tend to be more i don't say
cosmetic um they tend to be more
you know sort of safety and stabilizing
this area in that area
we're tearing down some things the old
concrete steam plant which is behind
maine sort of toward the garage and
warehouse and
the laundry facility that's being torn
down um
well the whole thing's being torn down
although i think the stack is still half
up
um and then an area in there there's a
there's a handicap accessibility being
built and um
handicap accessibility and i think a
stairway in the very so
main building the big building on top of
the hill has all kinds of wings and
tentacles to it
some of them are was that walker
walker is the big one on the corner sort
of backed by the high school it's sort
of at the corner of state and fruit
that's walker's actually one of the
nicest buildings in the state which is
beautiful
um but you come forward from that and
and maine is
if you go in the regular entrance big
scary building
yeah the big scary building right it's
where you know it's not the only
building with ghosts but supposedly
that's where the ghosts are
um and there's some really bad spots in
the basement like if you take the tour
yeah you don't want to know what
happened there i asked somebody once and
i go don't ask questions you don't want
to hear the answer to um
and um so they're poor parts of that
that probably will never be fixed like
the kent wing
and the peasley wing might have some
structural issues with it but it might
not
um but we do a little bit at a time but
in terms of major
giant rehab bancroft is the building i
was trying to think of
bancroft is probably the only remaining
building that's going to undergo a mass
undergo a significant expansion that
will then
create additional state office space
which will allow you not to
have to lease space the the theory is
when they when they develop the program
you know starting 20 years ago the idea
was to gradually move as many people
into state spaces
instead of least space as possible and a
lot of that was accomplished
it won't be entirely because if you
think of
think of dncr they're leasing space on
the
heights on chanel drive i think and
they're probably never going to come
into state space they're just
you know unless we built a building
because there's not you know
we got little bits here and little bits
there we don't have much extra
i mean i you know use this as an example
we had a discussion internally about
moving somebody who's in one area well
they should be
closer to these people and they're like
i'm like yeah let's move them
where exactly and uh
and we couldn't come up with a well if
these people move and then those people
move
and then what if agriculture we just
kicked out of the building entirely
great okay where would they go oh
nowhere okay so that doesn't work and so
you end up starting over
but so the campus a lot there are things
happening but right now
a lot of it is operational stuff oxygen
systems in the laundry
um building for example there's
something on our list right now
all right thanks thanks what's happened
with the old steam building
so the old scene building has we did a
significant
hazardous waste remediation
which was really a little bit scary
because
not everybody operates the same way uh
generally speaking you shouldn't have a
giant plastic
gallon jug of mercury just hanging out
under the stairs unmarked
oh my god as an example um
but um but we took care of that so we
took care of everything so that
um now it's being torn down and but to
tear it down you need to
clean it out first so that that doesn't
all become hazardous waste
and it is about i would say the
demolition project which is a capital
budget item in the
2021 capital budget is about half done
okay
um half the stack came down because it
started doing a pisa kind of thing oh
dear which you don't want
and so we uh we hired the boston chimney
company this is like a
really cool name i think for a company
boston chimney and tower
i think they're called i thought i want
to work for a company with a name like
that it just seems very solid
um so i'm sorry i digress
um well
thank you i'll ask you to repeat that to
my wife um
division of procurement and support
services we buy stuff
um it's a little more complicated than
that and i think gary's probably
listening and
um he would dispute that that's that's
what they do is they buy stuff but
um generally speaking you know we we bid
a lot of things and there are other
services fleet management is done out of
the state agency
it also includes surplus property where
the state unlike the federal government
actually sells its surplus property
rather than giving it away
and we make a buck off it um white farm
is the
is where most of that happens uh
we have a surplus food distribution
network that goes out of this
graphic services the state central
graphic services function is out of here
we manage the fleet we manage uh
merchant cards which is when people
pay us we manage procurement cards which
is when we pay people
um this agency is um
well i'm very proud of them i should say
during the pandemic there's probably
you know our agency has been hit pretty
hard by the pandemic not because people
got it but because
we're we work on stuff and everybody
gets repurposed you know the we set up a
warehouse and
and you know gary's got gary lynette as
the director gary's got a couple of
people
um who are basically 100 repurposed to
manage the warehouse
we don't manage warehouses that's not
something we do we don't do inventory
control
exactly but somebody had to so we did it
and um
two uh two very good chris and don
actually
are their names they're doing that about
we did an analysis and about
a little over 40 percent of their time
has been spent repurposed to
covidien sort of activities um so
they've been hit pretty hard on that
but they're managing to do everything
anyway so these are these are great
people making sure that when we buy
stuff
we buy it at a good price and that we
that we have a legal contract so that if
they don't deliver we don't pay
and that's true of that's true of road
salt
and it's true of n95 masks and from the
beginning they stepped up and said
we're not just going to call some guy in
china and go send us what you got we'll
send you a check and
we don't worry about whether we get it
or not we make sure that the flow and
everything is there they do a great job
um they're down a lot of people because
this is you know cassie talked a little
bit before about
um the tyranny of retirements where
somebody retires that's open
and the open position is the easiest to
eliminate um
so there's a there's a bundle here three
full time and one part time
it it helps purchasing everybody
everybody this is a trend uh a theme i
think you'll run into
in our agency everybody needs to be
cross-trained
um sarah and i have a monthly meeting
about about finance
and one of the big things that comes up
in that meeting is
how many people know how to do payroll
it can't just be one
it's got to be everybody how many people
know how to do ar how many people need
to
know how to do ap how many people know
how to do pick something
and and that's what's happening in
gary's agency it used to be that i only
do commodity buying nope
everybody buys everything even if you
specialize in something
everybody buys everything we can we can
cover each other
and that's and that's been great right
now because for example
we had the fleet manager position open
for about a year because of the
hiring freeze and all of that and the
guy who did p-cards
also did fleet it's not his job
but he did it because somebody had to
and they step up um
there's there's a point though at which
you can't keep doing that anymore that's
why we have a bundle of positions here
charlie before we go on you've got a
line here
graphic services established as a
revolving fund and page
110 to 112 and hb1 we also have sections
in hb2 related to that
could you go through that and then
representative burj is going to have a
question
sure graphic services
is three accounting units in your budget
and on page one
ten to one there's graphic services
administration
and then there's let me get it in front
of me photocopy and print shop
operations
yep um and that's sort of a holdover
from a day when those were different
things
we live in a world where they aren't
exactly different things anymore right
the the line between
how can we organize this so it matches
today
sarah just fainted because that's
something she has to do nevermind
we could we could actually look at doing
that it might make sense
so two of these this is the
administration is the general funds
and the two operation pieces are
dedicated funds they are
um people pay for their people pay for
their copies people pay for their
printing
and they're meant to cover themselves
and they do
essentially every year there's a there's
a little bit left over at the end of
every year we keep we're not
we're not meant to spend more than is
left over um and it varies usually from
between 13
000 and i think in the low in the last
five years and something like
60 000 is the high in that range um
where does that money go well right now
it lapses
till the general fund goes to like this
year
it would go to the general fund it would
pay off
it wouldn't pay off anything it would go
to you not you it would it would come
back to the
fund as a lapse so what you're proposing
i'm proposing to not do that anymore and
here's why
um and we we could cap it if we wanted
to but
there's not enough money that makes it i
think
necessarily worth capping
the salary adjustment fund we have a
salary adjustment fund in the state
when people retire so we budget we
we budget people's salaries people's
benefits in the state
when they retire typically they get a
large payout if you've been here
five or six years it's not that large if
you've been here 30 or 40 is quite large
and agencies have the ability for
generally funded positions
to go to the salary adjustment fund to
cover that
it's meant to cover that it's meant to
be the the excess it's swept out
and then used to pay that more than
anything else
um you can't do that with dedicated
funds
so you know normally this doesn't come
up much because it's not a lot of money
there aren't that many people
in in in dedicated funds
happens to be so i noticed this because
graphic services is apparently the one
of the greatest places to work in state
government
i got people there this is a story when
i started as commissioner i did a tour
of buildings
and and everybody where we have people
working i wanted to try to meet
essentially everybody who worked for the
department
i at most everybody and some of the
prisoners um
and i go over the graphic services i'm
talking to people i'm on the print shop
floor
and i'm talking to a guy brian is his
name he's actually retired since but
brain cummings
um and i'm like oh how long you've been
here and he said you know 41 years
like holy cow 41 years he goes yeah and
i'm not even the senior guy on the floor
and he points across the room to dave
roy is the guy's name has been there 46.
he's pushing 50 years now
and by the way 46 47 years
same room same print shop
same place i mean god bless him does
great work and he's wonderful
by the way when he retires it's a big
number
well if it's a general fund you go to
the salary adjustment fund
we're not setting aside money for that
and we can't set aside money for that
because there's no
because it's not that so in our agency
surplus property is a revolving fund
surplus food is a revolving fund largely
because of the federal component
and so that's why on page two it says
establish a state treasury a graphic
services fund which shall
shall be resolving fund administrated by
the department of
administrative services the funds will
be non-lapsing
and you're going you it goes on to talk
about
in the next section necessary costs of
administration management operations
activities etc
so that's what you're talking about
doing with this money
what's that for these people yep
okay anybody got a question on that
representative burge you had your hand
up and i think you were just
slightly farther down on that so go to
you were on the same page
i was reading ahead thank you my
question goes back to
purchasing when you purchase an item you
put it out for bid
uh in taking that into consideration do
you always go for the bottom line or do
you take
quality into account because in the long
run
the quality is in there it'll cost you
more
it's um you know it's a it's a really
good point and um you know there are
perils of low bid bidding
um it depends on the
it depends on the product and i'm going
to use a couple of examples so if you
think about something like uh like a
commodity like road salt
road salt is a great example we recently
did we actually did a reverse auction
which is a little bit like name neptune
if you're old enough to remember the
name neptune i can buy i can pay 23
cents for that salt oh yeah i can do it
for 22.
um and we we did that you save a little
money that way because road salt is road
salt
that's not technically true i i
understand but as long as you say
we need this this this this and uh
there's a technical component that i'll
get lost on but it has to be you know
this percentage of that or whatever but
as long as you meet that threshold well
if you meet a threshold
so what we'll do with things like office
supplies let's say
is we'll write a standard for what we
want
not any paper towel you come up with but
the paper towel has got to meet this
standard and the standard in this
standard
then you bid on it so that we're bidding
apples
and they're we're biting both sides of
the equation
nobody's trying to voice off on you
macintoshes or something
um and so the the bid spec
will have a great deal of detail and it
depends a little bit on
the product or the uh process that's
being bid services are bid to and what
service are you bidding
so quality can be taken into
consideration like when we do a
construction project
these are multi-million dollar bids the
the specs are just
you know uh page after page after page
that
that you and i or at least i anyway just
don't understand and we have
engineers who walk through it and
consultants to go through it you have to
meet those standards
and on a more complicated thing like a
construction project well we'll talk
about this later but
we actually then follow up to make sure
you're you're not giving us
you you didn't you're not giving it a
supply would instead of two by fours
or whatever thank you
it's it's a it's a good point uh uh
madam chair because the
um buying things is a lot harder than
people think
and it's a lot more complicated than
people think and um
for those for those reasons because
otherwise you you know if you're not
good at it you can get had
pretty easy okay so charlie you've also
got section three
related to the division of
procurement support services and hp2
which is on page two
section three so this is p
cards the the p card
or procurement card was established uh
five six seven years ago as a as a test
we buy things with a credit card
it used to be we bought a lot of stuff
with field purchase orders which are
have very little accountability
um and uh as a test we started buying
things with the
with the credit card we get rebate
revenue on it um
a negotiated value uh the more you spend
the higher your rebate the more basis
points you get back so to speak
was commissioner that's bill i had
co-sponsored was that right yeah okay
so you've heard of this before then oh
yeah um the um
but it doesn't look to me like section
three
makes a big change you've just made this
it's a little change but i want you to
know what you're doing before i
before i pretend it's too little um
currently
so p cards are getting bigger and bigger
and bigger and
and we're at the point where
it's not a side issue where you and and
the whole picard program was off budget
so it wasn't in the budget in the last
two or three budgets it's just off
budget but
we're not at the point where
occasionally we buy something with a
credit card
but pretty much we just write checks um
the
the spend on that side of the house gets
larger and larger and we need to be in a
position where the controls on
purchasing
are purchasing is purchasing how you pay
for it shouldn't matter
and um so the p card is i don't want to
be a stand-alone
set-aside i want it integrated into the
rest of the program
so there's a there's a sub there's a
bureau
in procurement bureau purchasing
property where
we meld it in and the rebates are not
set aside into an off-budget account
that stands by itself
they're merely um part of
they pay for purchasing and the p-card
manager and the p-card assistant manager
are not separate stand-alone off-budget
people they're just in the budget
like everything else this is a change
that actually
does uh financially help us and and
is replaces general fund dollars with
rebate revenue
to a small extent i don't want to
overstate it but it's
on a net value it's maybe 60 grand
does that sound right it varies
so for those who can't hear that was
sarah and she said
it varies from year to year on average
it's about 60.
um so um so it's a it's a slight net
benefit to the general fund
but slight well just so you know the
intent was
to start it as a pilot and if successful
to move it
and do exactly what you're doing well
good well look at that that's great
linda hodgson did not think it was going
to work
so she was amenable to a pilot fund
well i would say i think the pilot would
uh turn out to be a good idea because we
took
i went i think we took a few years
getting a getting a handle on it and
it's
instituting controls around it you know
one of the things you want to make sure
is that
you don't have people you know what the
right term is
thinking they're just running around
with a credit card but we have a very
a very strong control environment around
it um
and you know rules and waivers and you
know what you can use it for and what
you can't so
i think it's actually worked out to be a
great success
um okay that's procurement
yep we're ready to move on public works
the division of public works we build
stuff
um manage 160 million dollars worth of
projects they're about 120 active
projects in some stage of development
that's a rough number i don't have an
exact because what stage of development
is
is a question um public works um
uh are in the rsa's 21i
sections like 7980 and and in that
in that area um have some discussion of
this
as an aside public works grows out of
the
uh and the regulations on it grow out of
the time when the only
only one of my predecessors to go to
jail
at least that i'm aware of went to jail
in the 40s for
bid rigging essentially goofy
construction contracts that were not
very good he ended up doing federal time
i think
um we don't do that anymore i'm not at
risk for going to jail
um at least i don't think i am um
uh but there are a lot of so the state
standards on buildings we have to follow
state standards on buildings
um when we build stuff we don't build
whatever is cheapest we
uh we come up with plans and design so
that you're not leaning
on a wall and it falls down and that you
know
we don't have a lot of styrofoam walls
in state buildings we build to uh
to what's uh i think it's a 35-year
standard i might get that wrong but
that's about right
um general fund
projects are generally funded and
uh and that work is done sort of
straight up on this
uh capital projects and um non-general
fund projects are by state law required
to be
billed back to the agencies or build
back to the project is probably the
right way to put that
so that this unit has agency income to a
significant extent
it's about a third it goes up and down a
little bit each year depending on which
projects are approved
and and where they are so to speak in
the uh where the money is coming from
for them
so bundle five are they all general fund
or are they
that mixture they're all that mix so
every position in that
every position in this agency is
budgeted at 63-37
um that's just every in the position
account whatever that thing is called
in the position module that that's how
they're listed in in the budget
um we're going to look at over time
how we budget positions i believe that
clerk of the works
so the three kinds of positions of
public works right there's the project
managers the engineer and the architect
the guy who writes the plans the guy who
is the working
um on um on developing the
uh the plans that we build from and then
works on that project and works with the
construction company on that
um they're project managers is what we
call them
that's four of the positions we're down
a bunch our only electrical engineer for
example retired
we're down a mechanical i think we're
down an electric a mechanical and an
architect
and i don't know what the fourth is i
think it's a more entry level position
but there's a lot of fungibility there
we tried to assign a project to the
people
the guy who works on boilers is a guy
who always works on boilers
um i think it's typically dave goulet
for example because he knows boilers
and and and we don't have caitlyn work
on boilers because she's an architect as
opposed to
and so she works on so everybody has
like a you know who should this project
go to we'll probably put that one
with keith that kind of thing um that's
one piece there's a
there's a small sort of business
management staff which is the people who
make the paperwork go
and get all the things from the
contractors and then there's a
significant construction oversight when
you hear people talk about clerk of the
works
the clerk of the works is a person on
the construction project who
who does um who make sure that we're
that stuff is working that that we they
used to talk about slump uh slump tests
but um concrete breaks
we pour concrete and they and then they
test them
periodically i'm doing this because i
had to learn about concrete breaks
and i desperately want to want to use
that information
at some point and so this is my shot um
but we did that i mean it's they
actually when they pour the concrete
they do these you know
14 day 28 day and i think it's 56 day
samples
which they then break to see if we got
the right concrete and if it doesn't
break right at the 14 day break we make
them take it out and put it in again
that sort of follow follow-up on the
project is critical
and it's it people remember i think
starting in 2013
probably there was additional language
put in the capital project
for us to make sure that on capital
projects that we are hiring
um clerks and that they can be paid for
out of the capital funds
and that's the billing um
we've gotten by with this level of
staffing just real quick we've gotten by
with this level of staffing for the last
year and a half
because people will know there was a
capital budget freeze most capital
projects were either not being done
not being started or slowed so that the
workload
for the first
nine to ten months of the state of
emergency was um
uh less i don't want to say nobody was
working because that's not remotely true
but we weren't pushing as many projects
forward because i think there was some
concern about
you know there's a lot of financial
uncertainty for the first six or eight
months of the
of the of the pandemic people weren't
sure if this was if there was going to
be a huge
um revenue collapse or not and so
projects were slow
um we only need the people if we're
going to build stuff
but i think we are going to build stuff
sorry
no no that's fine the uh i thought this
might be a good place to weigh in on the
steam building that was built and i
think
whoever was responding you're smiling
see must have something to do with the
architecture that i think it looks nice
is it
what people um uh this
i don't actually know where we are but i
think it's the building right over there
actually over there uh by the police
station and sort of behind the
department of justice
we built a steam house and instead of it
being an ugly monstrosity
made out of out of green cinder blocks
or something
it's a brick building and by the way it
doesn't take much money
to make sure the building fits into its
surroundings and doesn't look like a
like a blight on the fabric of the city
of concord
um and we've got a lot of comments on
that the architect is actually from
vermont
um and uh just a you know real good guy
and um and they made a huge effort and
it was uh
the only thing i had to do with it and
i'm but i'm going to say this is i
insisted on reviewing the brick color
and which is really stupid but i was i i
like bricks
and i wanted to make sure we weren't
buying pink ones that we bought dark red
and so
okay that's public works
and knowing that you're tired of hearing
me at this point keep talking
i'm going to ask cassie to talk again
too see how i intro you cassie it's real
nice
um but we're going to talk about
financial data management the
uh most inappropriately named division
of our agency
because although that's what they do
it's so much more oh that's your line
isn't it did i steal that
so cassie keene is going to talk about
fdm
[Music]
hello again um the most
important role of fdm is that they
administer
new hampshire first which is our
business enterprise system
that is the backbone of state government
and it does
it manages every process you can think
of it manages
hr we we um if we hire somebody we put
them into the system
if they have a promotion if they
terminate and
all it manages every phase of the hr
process it manages our payroll and
produces our payroll
accounts payable accounts receivable and
also financial reporting
and so it's a very large undertaking and
as
charlie mentioned earlier there is a
capital budget
proposal for us to move
new hampshire first from an on-premise
system
to the cloud which we believe will
allow us to update the system more
regularly not get behind like we have in
the past
and it's going to give our agencies a
lot of
ease and flexibility to customize
financial reporting
for their own needs which i think is
going to help agencies it's going to
help the legislature it's going to help
the chief executive um so so we're very
um like enthused about moving to the
cloud
um there are four
different um increases in the fdm budget
and um one of those increases is for our
department-wide funding of the doit
budget
and that is approximately 221 thousand
dollars
there is increased debt over time
for um to allow staff to work overtime
to work on the cloud development
there is um an extra 200 000
that is to support um a das
department-wide um pc
replacement we found ourselves
shortchanged
when the pandemic hit first of all doit
has a standard where they recommend that
a pc be replaced every four years
we have nearly 250 computers that
exceed that age and when the pandemic
hit we had mostly desktops
we had some laptops and
so we had old equipment and we didn't
have equipment that was really
um flexible so the pandemic
taught us something so as we move
forward we want to get on a schedule
where we regularly budget in our budget
there's no highs and there's no
lows replacement pcs for our staff
and we're going to move to a model where
we use laptops and docking stations so
that if a staff person
is working remotely they simply bring
their laptop home with them
um and if they come back into the office
they bring their laptop in and they plug
it in at their desk
and um there is also
a an increase in the fdm budget
for our vendor who is called
infor they actually run our
new hampshire first system and there is
an
annual maintenance increase in the
budget and that's directly related to
our scheduling project which um as
as representative over knows we're right
now in phase one and we're going to be
launching this month
um a scheduling initiative to support
the department of corrections
and it is it's a it's a mechanism
it's it's actually a couple different
things it
it provides efficiency and scheduling
of staff and also it allows staff to
punch in
and punch out very expeditiously using
like a key card kind of
system and it's going to give the
department of corrections a lot more
control about who's working where and
when
and and next phases of another project
that's underway called strategic
sourcing
and with we are short three positions in
the
in the current proposed budget to
support
fdn and it's bundle three and we
mentioned it earlier when we talked
about the bureau of accounts
um the interesting thing about new
hampshire first is
it is administered by fdm but it is
literally a system that requires
contributions from all over
our departments so um when i said
there's a module that helps support
hr our division of personnel is heavily
involved in
how is the new hampshire first meeting
personnel needs
uh financial reporting obviously bureau
of accounts is involved
uh payroll bureau of accounts so
there are three positions in bundle
three and and
those three positions would support the
initiative to move to the cloud
cassie does fdm have any
sections in hb2 it didn't seem to me
that
any of those sections directly related
to fdm did i read those correctly
you did there is nothing in hospital ii
related to ftm
thank you
see no questions i bet you're going to
get to recontinue
with risk and benefits when we turn the
page somehow
maybe maybe um the uh the only thing i
want to say sarah did point out that
there's a section
about the continuation of the funding
for scheduling software in hvac
what section is that charlie
h7 thank you
representation
it is seven eight seven
line twenty four section thirty line
twenty four
so in the last budget um the last budget
included as as one of the operating
uh uh things instead of a capital thing
it if you remember two years ago there's
a whole bunch of money in house bill 2
that was that was the equivalent of sort
of capital money but it was being spent
in hospital too there was a
there was an amount of money for the
scheduling process and we're not
a hundred percent sure if that's going
to be spent by june
30th or not but we're using it for the
for the project it might actually be
close
so you would like to have a decision we
would like to have an extended in the
in the equivalent of a capital budget
extension
thank you thanks sarah for saving us
good catch sir
madam chair would it be okay if i asked
cassie to do the division of risk and
benefits as well i'm
sure you were going to actually
hello again um
so uh the next couple of slides relate
to division of risk and benefits and the
first slide which is number 12
really just talks about what is this
division of risk and benefits
and um i this this committee
representative ober are very very
familiar with
our division of risk and benefits which
is led by director joyce pittman who has
done a wonderful wonderful job
sarah and i used to be a part of um risk
and benefits so it's near and dear to
our hearts
in any event we we administer the
employee
and the retiree health benefit plans and
we
cover approximately 37 000 people
which is our employees and their
families and
our retirees and spouses generally
speaking we also in the division
of we we spend by the way about 600
million dollars in a biennium for health
care so the work that we do
to contain costs is um
one of our major goals it's it's i think
good for you folks to know that employee
benefits
are defined by the collective bargaining
agreements
and the legislature defines the
scope of the retiree health benefits so
we
don't have the ability to
simply change benefits on our own again
we have to look to collective bargaining
into the legislature in the
in the case of retired health we also
secure property and casualty insurance
for state agencies and
and that's the bullet that we'll focus
on when we look at what's different
about this budget
and we administer the workers
compensation
program for the state of new hampshire
in this budget you're going to see some
differences
and it's an increase in total funds in
class 211
and um what we did is
budget in it's a i think it's a lot like
the um
the buildings we budgeted in
class 211 and risk
more than more than 15 insurance
policies
and those policies are funded by
agencies and there's agency
income to support that expense
and we this is a change in in the
budgeting of the policies
how they're budgeted not the amount and
the reason we did this is that um
over the years we've come to realizing
risk that
we've been put in a position with our
scarce resources
of having to be a collection agency to
collect money from agencies and to make
sure that they're paying policies to the
carriers
who are ensuring the state of new
hampshire's interests and
it's a terribly inefficient policy way
to run a business
and so by moving the expense into
the risk budget where we in risk will be
able to pay those
carriers when do and we can
efficiently work with the agencies to
collect the revenue from them that
supports that expense
so um that's why you see a difference in
class 211
and representative ober in particular
we know we've talked about cyber
insurance
um this is a general fund expense that's
been
in the division of risk and benefits
since approximately 2015
it does cover cyber security
coverage for the entire state of new
hampshire
all three branches the secretary of
state and the other constitutional
entities
and as i said it is a general fund
expense in this budget
we did look at so people will know
that representative ober during the the
what do they call the governor's budget
hearings in
november i think said something to us
about hey why is that budgeted there as
general funds instead of
uh costs allocated like all the other it
expenses through
doit class 27 class 27.
so we looked at it because it but it was
already done
so it so the budget already done we
so the beginning of the governor's phase
we sort of talked about it but um
because it was already there um i think
where the governor's office was was
was they said if that can be done in the
legislative phase we're not opposed to
it but
we're not doing it yet right because
that would change every class 27 in
every agency
so we talked to dennis about it um
no don't joe doesn't know that so we uh
um if something comes up
where we're changing the class 27 in
every state
agency budget anyway um
then we might consider doing that at
that appropriate time
this amount just understand what cassie
said which i think was very clear
because she gives clear
clear descriptions would actually move
into class
211 yes
see cassie gives clear descriptions i
got it
okay there you go there we go okay
so now retiree health where we see
miraculously
lots of money the first time i said
cassie have to tell you the first time
the commissioner said at the governor's
budget hearings in november that this
had gone down
my heart sank because i said to myself
how many retirees died because of covert
because i couldn't imagine how else it
had gone down
um now we have a wild success story to
tell
and i want to applaud and get on my
knees and thank the work of the division
of risk of benefits
because i think it's it's wonderful news
not only for
our department but for the state and for
you folks who are struggling in this
very
hard fiscal time so um
we in 20 what what how can we attribute
this success
and we can we can attribute it to the
um transfer of the medical benefits for
medicare retirees not
not prescription drug by the way from
a self-funded model to a medicare
advantage model
we actually did this beginning in
calendar year
2019 and we were under contract with
anthem for our medicare retirees and we
converted them from a self-funded model
to
medicare advantage and what it did was
it
it brought in federal funds that were
paid directly to the carrier who's
incentivized to coordinate care under
on behalf of retirees and that resulted
in substantial savings to the plan in
the current biennium
and so the first bullet you see on this
page you can see that we estimate a
lapse
in general funds in the amount of 77
million
in fiscal year 21 and we believe that
that lapse will go up to 10 million for
the entire
biennium then in 2020
we um that that contract with anthem
was um ending at 12 31
2020. so we did a procurement for a
medicare advantage
carrier for um
for our medicare retirees and we knew
what has happened in since we've been
talking about
retiree health a lot with this committee
with
finance committees in both the house and
senate is that the market in new
hampshire has evolved
and when we were first confronted with
shortfalls in
retiree health and looking at various
cost containment strategies
we didn't have medicare advantage in our
toolbox
and by the time we got to 2018
the market was maturing here in new
hampshire and that's why we could
move our members to a medicare advantage
product
in 2019 then when we went out to bid we
knew that there were
other carriers in the market apart from
anthem
and and when we went out to bid we
expected there to be
a lot of competition and there was and
we achieved
really really amazing rates and
um and the savings that you see
uh for governors recommended a 17.6
million dollar reduction off of fiscal
year 21
and then in 23 uh an additional 11.8
that's attributed to that procurement
and
i i really can't emphasize enough the
very hard
and um and wonderful work of the
division of risk and benefits again it's
director joyce pittman
it's her staff with deputy director
margaret blacker
this is a lot of work for them not just
in the procurement arena by the way but
changing carriers especially with
retirees
is is a big deal there's a lot of
implementation that goes
along with it there's a lot of support
that we need to
provide to our retirees so that they are
comfortable
with the changes that they're
experiencing and
one thing i think we've been doing quite
well in risk and benefits with respect
to our retirees
is to educate them probably going back
to 2015 at this point
that um we all need to expect change and
procurement is going to be one of those
arenas where
um we have um we have the ability
to save money and that's by going out to
bid for
our medical carrier for our um
prescription drug
benefits carrier and and they should
expect change if that's one way that we
can help contain
costs so again wonderful results
wonderful work by our division of risk
and benefits
i i want to add to that that um
[Music]
we as a department we we play small ball
we hit a lot of singles
every day that's what we do our job wake
up
try and put the ball in play and hit a
single this is a home run
and we're not in the home run business
but we had a hell of a good grand slam
here
and i'm taking credit for it and i'm not
letting it go
and i want everyone to not throw this
slide away you can dump everything else
in the trash but for god's sakes please
keep this one
because it's this result is ridiculous
it's insane and it's and it's not going
to happen again
but that's a home run and
i just want to say especially since i
know it wasn't because retirees died
from covet
yes i think we actually we think we
weren't hit that hard
i think we think our people did pretty
well yeah i gathered that when
cassie sent me some stats on something
else
um representative emerick please thank
you
i would like to take a moment of
personal privilege
as a participant of the program as a
state rep we can
we can go on the as a paid participant
we can go on on the retiree program
if you're or the regular program i'm
assuming
my monthly cost went from over 600
to about 450 so it's a home run for us
too
well that's great i'm glad to hear that
yeah so thank you very much
very happy to hear so cassie we're sorry
you didn't get any credit that the
commissioner took all of it but good job
well that's the way it goes
thank you now i'm in trouble okay
commissioner i
i've got my index here of hp2 which
lba bless her heart somehow managed to
get this out
almost as soon as we got hb2 i do not
know
how they do all the great work they do
we have not talked about
a couple of these instances so i'm going
to start with
section 5 and see what page that's on
section five starts on page two so can
you
run us through these because we need to
sure so section five is
is about bureau planning and management
um
one of the things we're doing as an
agency in the plant and property side is
trying to
the the the old construct is that
they're all they're a bunch of
silos court facilities as a sire general
services as a silo
and and uh facilities and asset
management
as a silo in different buildings so you
know for example if you think of the
state hospital campus there are four
different
uh building management teams for that
campus right
hhs patient occupied buildings are one
group they
they do they the old hhs buildings are
we administer under bfam
there are other buildings administered
under general services and unemployment
security does its own building
it's ridiculous for a guy mowing the
lawn to stop this is a
this is a dumb example but it makes the
point um
like you don't stop and go oh wait i'm
in enemy territory now i need to not
i i'm okay mowing spalding but i'm not
going anywhere near dollop and i'm gonna
go up to this line so we're so we're
doing that uh planning and management is
a bureau of one person
and just as a general principle i think
the duties of
the duties of our department should be
uh enumerated in state law either at the
division level or the
or the um department level and that's
all that's all that is
and it just allows for the sort of ease
of operation of the agency
um section six we kind of talked about
that a little bit but this
is the payment and procurement card fund
and that's just uh uh p-card rebates
will be part of uh
revenues and uh p-cards will be on
budget instead of off-budget and
and supporting just part of purchasing
so that brings us to section eight which
starts at the bottom of page four if
you're tracking that it
remotely uh the consolidation of hr
function this is something that has been
in the budget for geez it might even be
a decade at this point
do we need this well what it does is
it's part of a mandate for us to
to to do things and and it allows us the
statutory authority to do certain things
and
when this was first put in the budget
there was a notion that
that things are either a centralized or
b decentralized
no no such thing as c um frankly in
looking at
particularly the personnel system and
the hr functions of the state
we've decided that c is the right answer
not a or b
for example the department of safety has
a more than a thousand employees and an
hr function
and a staff and and does it very well
how they operate and how their employees
are served by the hr function
is very different from say the
department of labor
uh fewer than 90 employees they have a
one person who does hr and payroll and
some other stuff
and you can't be a
you can't be an army of one and be
and know everything about fmla fully
understand the
flsa and the federal law and be
uh adept at every piece of the operation
so one of the things we're looking at is
amalgamating functions and
and we call it an hrsu human resources
support or service unit i forget which
is the yes but the idea of saying
we're going to we're going to merge
these people and they're going to work
we have a couple of mou's right now
where for example
labor's hr person sits in the division
of personnel
and is is trained on some things well
you you'll have three people that work
for three agencies
but each of them can become more adept
at some things
if you're if you're a unit of one at an
agency
and you do a significant fmoa claim one
one time and then don't face it again
for nine months
you know your skill level is just
naturally not going to be as
as good so that language is there to
allow us
the ability to just function that way
and without
without need all right um
section nine is
also yours and that starts on page
six oh section nine is the language of
this is
this is language that's in every year
that allows the state employee health
plan
to be extended to uh unrepresented
confidential etc employees
it's a it's uh pro forma not pro forma
it's
it's necessary language for the
operation of the plan and we've done it
every we do it every year
absolutely representative elishman you
have a question uh certainly the
language is familiar to us that serve on
fiscal but i had a question
it says uh may does that say shell now
or what what page and what line are you
looking at i'm sorry page six still nine
uh line uh 18 and 19 where the fiscal
committee of the general court may
approve changes
don't you say shell because we always
approve those we have in the past on
fiscal interest
we have approved it i believe that is
existing language
not so i think it is existing language
and i think the difference between mae
and chell
here and i i understand what
representative leishman is getting it
um i think that it's meant to ensure
uh and and cassie's going to correct me
on this because she's a lawyer
um it's meant to ensure that the fiscal
committee
can do what it wants fiscal committee
doesn't have to approve changes they can
reject them
is that right cassie is that the
difference between may and
shall
[Music]
we may approve or we shall approve it
doesn't
still i think it should say so because
any of the changes
should require the uh approval of the
fiscal committee
um it certainly would be art would be
our
expect expectation anyway so check with
them and i think i'm sure we'll be okay
with that
thanks thanks okay so section 10 is
really kind of a doit
thing but it applies to all agencies
because it says
that you may provide documents by
electronic mailing in lieu of man
you're not opposed to that are you no i
think we're
i think we actually recommend it yeah
absolutely
um section 12 talks about a repeal will
you talk to us about that
oh that's part of the um plant and
property
change in 2005 a big chunk of buildings
on the hospital campus were transferred
hhs used to have its own property
function okay
and they were and so if we're if we're
merging bureaus
not merging bureaus merging functions um
they're the only agency that has a
separate mou so this way
everyone's the same everyone's the same
okay so i think your last
section in hb2 unless i'm wrong is
section 11
which is found at the bottom of page six
section 11. and this was the suspension
and she's not that we put in for you
because we did not
staff you yes because the goal is
if we can't staff you we don't want you
getting a ding
in a performance on it because the
legislature failed to give you what you
need
these are the ones that had been worked
out before and you know obviously as a
as an entity we do
you know we do everything we can and we
do parts of everything we can but
there's some
some pieces of this that are that are
just necessary for us to
not do or we would require significant
staff increases
so i assume we want to keep that because
that's why we put it in there and you're
already short staffed in other areas so
i don't see us
going in now and adding something that
wasn't left before
and they're the same things as as past
years it's it's not a different set of
uh
items do you have any other sections in
hb2 other than the ones i
have found um section 14 and 15. uh
they're starting
and 15. okay we will pay about
14 starts at the bottom of page seven
and they're the same thing it's related
to the medical subsidy
there has been there's actually a house
bill that that um
is working on this as well but um this
is this is our
the retiree health plan is uh funded by
something called the medical subsidy
which was passed as part of the 2005
budget this is unrelated
completely unrelated to the thing called
medical subsidy
um that local gov some local employees
have in the retirement system ours is
ours is different it's not a subsidy to
an individual
it's a subsidy to the state plan it was
put in the budget in o5 and
zl5 might have been o3 um
i just remember jack barnes was fine it
was senate finance chair
laid out huge difficulty agreeing on the
budget that year
um and uh um
senate rejected the house version and
started over which
wouldn't happen this year um the
could no i'm sure no it'll be fine
everything will be great don't just take
but they'll take what you do and say
yeah that's good
yeah i doubt it um i doubt it it's my
hunch um uh anyway so the medical
subsidy is supposed to
uh pay for employee costs there was
later a premium was established and the
premium is in addition to and
notwithstanding
other payments so we thought
at admin services that the language in
addition to and notwithstanding was
clear because it
kind of seems clear in addition to and
notwithstanding
um the retirement system is not clear
and they
and they think that um and they don't
care which clarification this has been
their position
we don't care if it it's what you think
should happen or not what you think
should happen
we think it should be clarified um
you know we had the attorney general's
office do an analysis on this and um
this changes the law in all the places
that it occurs so there's not any future
and it leaves the addition to and
notwithstanding language in so the
people understand that
the premium isn't in it is in addition
to
and notwithstanding other payments and
the medical subsidy
that we fund we send money to hh or to
the retirement system and they send it
back
um is to fund the retiree health plan
and that's what it's for
and so 14 does group two 15 does the
same thing for group one is that correct
um i believe that's right it's it's it's
the the law i mean frankly this
this these sections of the law are a
little bit
if you were going to do a rewrite of
statute i'm not
yes and nobody is and that's why they're
like this because they
they they date to a period when the
retirement system did things that they
don't do now
and when uh and when we didn't self-fund
our
our policy but but the languages
uh is about the medical subsidy and it's
important if it
if it doesn't go through there are about
600 and some retirees
right now that we are having to bill for
their premium because the retirement
system
is unsure whether they can bill
um unsure whether they can collect so
they're not
they used to and now they're not and
this clarifies that and this clarifies
that 100
and it makes sure that the the medical
subsidy goes to support the plan
if it doesn't we would need additional
general funds
okay i think the commissioner has given
us
a good run-through from an hb2
perspective das
has sections 1 through 9
inclusive and then 11
12 13 14 and 15.
[Music]
representative taberge wants to look at
section one with a possible amendment
representative leishman is going to be
checking with lba
on section nine
could i have a motion from a committee
member
to approve sections 2 3
4 5 6
7 8 11
12 13 14 and 15.
madam chair if i may i have my hand up
i'm not sure
just a moment sorry representative
lishman
i mean i'm saying represent emmerich
moved representative
leishman seconded questions on the
motion representative hatch
not so much on the motion but it's on
the um
section one so are we going to section
one we are not moving on that at the
moment i excluded that because there was
a question by
representative burge and you may be in
the same situation
so we are not moving on that one we are
also not moving section nine where
representative leishman has a question
we're removing the one
we're moving the ones that we don't have
a question on i'm sorry
just man i'm sure i have a a request to
the commissioner prior to
him leaving that's all so okay so i'll
come back to you after we handle this
motion this is just one thing
commissioner's not leaving immediately
cassie is your hand up for a reason
uh it is and it's just to make sure that
the commissioner covers slide
17 with you before we close
i will thank you okay
so we have a motion
made by representative emmerich seconded
by representative leishman
to approve house bill 2 sections
2 3 4
5 6 7
8 11 12 13
14 15. see no
additional discussion with the clerk
please
call the roll on the motion if you are
in favor please say yay when your name
is called if you're opposed please say
nay
chairman yes
vice chairman yes
yes
madam chair yes can i hear uh
representative tuberge
is your microphone on bob
no it's not i apologize we have a little
technical difficulty here
it's what we would call pebcak do you
know what pebcak is bill
no idea pebcak is an acronym that stands
for
it's a techie thing exists between chair
and keyboard
i think we fixed the problem
you want to start with the roll call
again representative
and to add to the chair's remarks uh i
am french so i have an excuse
okay all right for the roll call
uh chairman ober yes
vice chairman emerick the clerk votes
yes
representative griffin yes uh
representative lishman
representative hatch yes representative
walsh
yes okay it's unanimous madam chairman
okay the motion passes seven to nothing
um
charlie we obviously we have a couple
more things still going
number one cassie wants you to talk to
us about another section and then
clearly
represent hatch has a question and
others may too
before you go okay do you want to start
with representative hatch
no we want to start with your okay thank
you too and
um and i'm going to pretend that i
wasn't going to forget that um
okay that's a good plan um section
uh we have a technical correction of the
budget which is on page 17
and then details on page
oh thank you i have that reverse okay
sarah says
sarah said there's a summary on 16 in
detail on 17.
um so when we budgeted i told you that
plant
property is budgeted in this in the
agency 16 is judicial appointment
service
i'm sorry i'm sorry slide
17 on our presentation i'm sorry
okay so on slides not in
hb2 guys yeah i'm sorry
this is we're into the errata on page 17
in the slides which we hadn't gotten to
anyway so okay we're proceeding on
commissioner so we budgeted six hundred
thousand dollars wrong
as a short version um the money is
budgeted correct in agency budgets
and it is budgeted as general funds in
ours when it should be budgeted
as agency income
it said at least it's an error in the
right direction
i'm hoping maybe we can use the 600 000
because you already think we have it
i believe that some of our positions but
this is the venus is online and she's
our our lba
associate who works on these
nancy is this clear to you so we can get
amendments to make this happen yes i i
believe some adam chair thank you all
right
charlie and if it isn't we'll work with
her on we will make that happen and she
if she has a question she'll reach out
to you
good thank you represent hatch he's
still not leaving but you had something
you want to talk about
yes thank you madam chair just going
back to the reimbursement for the
sheriff's department
if you could commissioner i mean it's a
matter of
as uh to burj mentioned it's a matter of
logistics more so than the matter of
population that can impact that but what
would be helpful if you could send me
um the history for at least the last
biennium by
county of the reimbursements i i just
want to look at it i mean it's uh
to see the impact the overall
expenditure is a million but i'm
um just to get a better sense of that
that's awesome oh good yeah we can do
that
sure if you get that to janet she'll get
it out to all the division members
because obviously there are a couple of
people with questions about this but
everybody would probably like to see
that good i'll try and get that to janet
um this week
that's great thank you commissioner
thank you madam chair no no thank you
okay the only other thing madam share
there's an item that's not ours but i
want to call to
your attention because it isn't ours in
house bill 2.
back to hp2 section 19 on page nine
section 19 on page nine
is related to the sale of the lakes
region facility
yes and i know somebody might ask about
that and
or later wish they had um
this is not something this is not
something we um
we work with the lakes region
development commission
because obviously who else would they
work with um
naturally right um and and uh mike
connor who's our
who's retired from us but working
part-time has been helping them
um so that's in the law and the sale is
a process that we would do
um and i would just point out to you
that that this is something that they're
they're looking at selling but this
would um
we're agnostic about this it does it
does change the way it's sold and i
think
the biggest thing it does is take out
historical resources and
um the legislature's long-range planning
commission
um and just so i think that it becomes
an executive branch function
um without the legislative involvement
i'm not sure we're gonna
proceed with that i just just wanted to
point out that
yeah we're agnostic
no i i don't think so i think he's still
on the commission too
yes he is um
we miss him his wife and
well both of them but his wife really
likes to be warm in the winter
and warm means a lot of time in florida
or you know the bahamas or
someplace yeah so we we understand that
i
absolutely understand that yeah and are
jealous so
the finance committee is not conducive
to no and he
he told me he promised her that he would
not run again after he got through
that session i mean you know and i
understand that life is short you need
to do
the good things for yourselves i hear
that
now before commissioner arlen house and
his staff leave
any last questions on any topic they've
covered i really appreciate you for
being so thorough with
helping us go through your budget so
effectively we're happy to talk anytime
i see no questions oh representative
leishman i spoke too soon i'm gonna take
personal privilege like uh
mr tracy did here earlier but i just
want to say
thank you um i was here when we had past
commissioners i go way back to
commissioner hill i believe his name was
and i shouldn't say this but he could
never get a straight answer out of
commissioner oh i remember him
i shouldn't say that but it's true but i
think charlie you're such a credit
to this agency how you've turned it
around and
um you know people often say they can't
sleep at night because of a certain
thing i think i could probably say sleep
better at night knowing
you're the commissioner of the dis so
thank you what a remarkably nice thing
to say i
i um but i don't really do anything
i um you're too modest i have an
ingredient no i seriously i have an
incredible staff and
and you know uh between sarah joe cassie
and
uh we have some of the best division
directors i said to someone all the
smartest people in state government work
for me
and it all starts at the time and it's
well let's uh that's very nice
to say and i'm going to take that thank
you we want to know if joe's buying your
lunch
since he didn't have to talk at all but
we're not going to ask that while we're
live so
commissioner sarah thank you for being
with us cassie and joe
thank you for zooming in and answering
questions
we are now going to be in a five minute
recess so i would ask everybody
to mute themselves
foreign
all right the time being 11 o'clock
we are back from our very brief recess
and i'd like to welcome
banking commissioner jerry little
welcome to division one we have two
members at home you can see them on the
monitor in front of you
and the other five of us are here so we
are delighted
you are with us and i think
i got a handout from you this morning
i've kind of lost track
yes you should have yes i did thank you
thank you uh chairman ober members of
the committee
i was very excited to see that i had the
option of coming to see you in person to
testify
um one of the wonderful things about
this process is the people that we work
with and it's
been a little bit of a struggle not to
be able to see folks in the past most of
people are testifying
if you feel comfortable are taking off
their masks we have as you see
over here in the corner extra filtration
equipment it
is cleaning the air five times every
hour which is wonderful
and there's one in the back doing the
same most of us are wearing our masks
but you're going to be talking longer
and it's a lot harder to get oxygen
so welcome thank you very much i'm
pleased to present the bank department's
budget proposal for
2022 and 2023 biennium
um the department goes through a very uh
inclusive process to draft up its budget
every two years
we have a very strong management team
directors of each division
come together as do many other folks
that are the subject matter experts that
we deal with
and as a team we deliver this budget to
you
the bank department is structured in two
separate divisions there's the banking
and trust
supervision division which is accounting
unit 2046
and then there's the consumer credit
division which is accounting unit 2043
the banking trust supervision division
is probably the one that people think of
the most because
that group is responsible has
jurisdiction over examination and
consumer
safety for 16 banks
nine credit unions and 34 non-depository
trust companies the other half of our
business however is the consumer credit
division
a separate accounting unit accounting
unit 20043
and they oversee literally thousands of
licensees
that provide products and services to
consumers in the state of new hampshire
so think mortgage bankers
auto lenders small loan companies money
service
businesses money transmitters we do all
of that with
54 positions not all of them filled
however
we have five that are funded but vacant
we have six positions that are currently
funded but don't have anybody in them
right now and we may have plans
we do have plans to possibly use some of
those positions
within this upcoming biennium that we're
talking about
your handout says they're unfunded yes
five
unfun uh six unfunded yes five funded
i'm sorry
the five funded positions we may be
seeking to use some of those
uh in the in the coming biennium
um we are not seeking any new positions
i haven't for the past two years we
won't uh
in the 2223 biennium either
the next bullet you see does mention
that we may consolidate
or reclassify some of the positions that
we currently have funding for that are
open
we may actually do some reclassifying
reorganization of positions that are
funded
primarily due to the fact that
the non-depository trust company charter
in the state of new hampshire is really
taking off we're receiving numerous
applications every year for new trust
company charters it's unusual
and we may need to redirect some of our
staff to focus on
some of those the proposals that we're
receiving these days
are quite unique and propose
extremely large financial institutions
as a result
the bank department does not use any
general funds we don't use any federal
funds
100 percent of our revenue is
other sources agency income in other
words
we're entirely funded by the fees and
fines that will collect during the year
and if there is a shortfall
we have the ability within state statute
to issue an assessment against all of
the entities that we have jurisdiction
over
and to collect that shortfall from from
them so we always balance out at the end
of the year
the budget proposal that we submitted
was slightly larger
than that which was suggested by the
governor we met
with then budget director max zellum
and discussed why there was a difference
between what we thought we needed and
what they needed
and concurred on the figures that the
governor
has proposed for the bank department so
we're very
comfortable with the idea that we can
run the department in 2022 and 2023 with
the figure of
six million six hundred forty six
thousand one hundred and fifty three
dollars that the governor has proposed
for operating both of those
accounting units 2046 and 2043.
the governor's proposal is about uh 222
000 less for 22
than we are authorized to spend this
year in 2021
the 2023 proposal is about 95
000 hardly a material difference in the
world of the state government
from what we are currently spending
authorized to spend in 2021
with that said um that's the sort of the
nuts and bolts of our budget it's pretty
simple
um we're a small organization um we're
self-funded
uh and we have tried over the past
several years to become as lean
as we possibly can be there were
questions that were proposed
to agencies from chairwoman ober
regarding
addition of staff as i've mentioned for
answers to questions
one and two we do not plan any new
full-time
staff we do not plan to bring on any new
part-time staff we have nor have we
needed to
eliminate any positions within our
budget to meet the governor's
recommendation as i mentioned we have
five funded but not
filled positions and we believe that
to address the challenges the department
is facing we will be able to use those
currently funded positions
through reclassification and and
reorganization to meet all
challenges ahead of the department you
see
um some detail there uh
in answer to question number four as a
little bit of specifics about how we
might do that one of the positions we
are talking about needing to fill
currently funded
and would be funded in the 2223 proposal
is a paralegal position in our legal
division and we may need to activate
that position to keep up with the legal
work that's coming our way as a result
of the increase in non-depository trust
company charters
question number six uh
we'll probably want some discussion uh
the question asked whether or not there
was
anything within state law that we're
required to do
um that we may not want to be doing
anymore
and it also relates to the answer at
question number eight which is on the
last page
the new hampshire banking department has
been required
since the late 80s early 90s to
manage the public deposit investment
pool
also known as the dip the padip
is a service provided to
municipals municipal municipalities
school districts
other governmental units
for holding their cash
the idea is that we would aggregate it
we will aggregate it we do aggregate it
in a pool
we do contract with
an administrator pfm is the name of the
company that we've been using
and they invest the cash in an effort to
try to generate
a return on those
available liquid funds for cities and
towns counties school districts etc all
across the state of new hampshire
the public deposit investment pool
manages a pool
until recently where it dipped down a
little bit but generally it's about a
quarter of a billion dollars
on any given day 250 million dollars
that is collected from municipalities
school districts etc governmental units
across the state of new hampshire
and sent out for investment the public
deposit investment pool has attempted to
try
to find ways to invest deposit the funds
i should say rather than invest deposit
the funds
with community banks and credit unions
in the state of new hampshire
to one support those industries and two
to put the money
that is collected generally through
taxation
in the state of new hampshire back to
work in the state of new hampshire
they've not been able to do that they
can attract a better rate for those
funds by taking them
nation nationwide or in fact
internationally
and putting them with other entities so
that quarter billion dollars on any
given day
is leaving the state of new hampshire
and going to places where it can get a
better rate of return
because ultimately that is the fiduciary
responsibility of the public deposit
investment pool is to maximize the
return
for the taxpayers from the cities and
towns and school districts etc
who have put the money with them most
states do run public deposit investment
pools
new hampshire is the only state in the
entire country
that puts its public deposit investment
pool in its banking department
that creates a conflict of interest for
the managers of the banking department
because on most days of the year
we're wearing a hat that tells us that
we have a responsibility to make sure
that the banks
and the credit unions and the other
entities that we regulate are safe
strong
operating very effectively and on the
days that i become
responsible for the public deposit
investment pool i take off that hat
and i try to see how fiercely can i
compete with those banks that i regulate
how much money can i take out of their
liquid funds that are being lent back
into the communities
to send someplace else to gain a better
return for the cities and towns and
school districts of the state of new
hampshire
i've struggled with that conflict
between my responsibility as bank
commissioner to
consumers and the chattered entities
that we represent
and my responsibility to the public
deposit investment pool
and the municipalities and counties and
school districts
that use that we've talked about this
for a couple of years now at the public
deposit investment pool it's been a
constant issue on our quarterly meeting
agendas
i have met with a number of entities to
see if we couldn't stimulate
interest in pursuing a form
that is used in many of the most of the
other states every other state other
than new hampshire
which would be to have a separate entity
take
responsibility for the public deposit
investment pool from the banking
department
uh and i've not been able to generate
there's been plenty of conversation
but i've not been able to generate
interest in anybody to take that over
most recently what i recommended to the
public deposit investment pool is that
the banking department be allowed at
least to recover
expenses that it incurs on behalf of the
public deposit investment pool
as i mentioned at the outset when i
discussed the source of funds and the
fact that the bank department is
self-funding and that would balance our
budget every year
we're funded by the banks and the trust
companies and the credit unions
and we send all of them a bill at the
end of the year
that says this is the shortfall here is
your pro rata share
please send us a check so what we have
is a situation where
i'm doing my best to hold down the
assessment
that we're charging to the entities that
we have jurisdiction over so that we're
not
impacting them dramatically fiscally
through the operation of the department
and on the other hand
that assessment includes the time spent
by
banking department lawyers and other
staff to work on the public deposit
investment pool which then competes with
them
so we're asking those entities to pay
the freight to the entities that i'm
operating the public deposit investment
pool that's competing with them to take
deposits out of those entities
and send them someplace else around the
world to be invested rather than being
invested here in new hampshire it's been
operating this way for a long time
i understand that and i think we've been
very careful
and patient and listening and a lot of
conversation going on
before we propose anything we have a
concept that we
are prepared to pursue my sense is that
it is public policy and it probably is a
little bit much to put into house bill
2.
and that would be to suggest a change in
the statute
in rsa 383 that would remove the public
deposit investment pool from the banking
department
and have a separate commission um
created
for it to operate the public deposit
investment pool
most sorts of commissions exist today it
would not be unique to the public
deposit investment pool it's a common
operation in state government in new
hampshire at this point in time
because we're talking the budget and
there is a fiscal hook to it
and again i realize that when we
submitted the original budget pass
package back many many months ago um had
this thought
come up it would have been i believe on
form
e of the budget submission in the
efficiency budget
um scheme
but it only came up recently within the
past couple or two three weeks
this idea of at least charging
the pool for the expenses that
we incur on its behalf so you will see
on the last page
of the handout that we've provided you
under number eight
um suggested language that we would ask
you to consider adding to house bill 2
and it's roman 5 at the bottom of that
page the italicized bolded language
is is the addition the previous language
from romans 1 through 4
already exists roman 5 would allow the
banking department
um to submit a request for reimbursement
to
the manager of the public deposit
investment pool
for reimbursement of exact costs we
would use the per diem rate that we
charge
other entities that we perform functions
for that's
not a cheap rate it's about a thousand
seventy four dollars i believe right now
per staff person per day
that we work on them so you'll see in
this language that
we've added um
that the let me just find it for you so
i can
uh well at the start of roman four the
actual cost
incurred by the department
um
however you see at the fourth line from
the bottom
the requirement that no entity shall be
charged or pay less than one full day
shall not apply
is in this language which means that we
will track our time by the hour and only
bill by the hour on this not by the day
which we believe would be would be fair
to the public deposit investment pool
we're not looking to make money on them
we're only looking to recover
our expenses
that's my presentation chairman
other questions of the committee
representative walls
thank you madam chair um with respect to
this public deposit investment pool this
is going to show my naivete
but why would this not fall into the
state treasurer i mean i thought she
was responsible for investing the money
the state treasurer does sit on the
board of the public deposit investment
pool
advisory committee um we began this
conversation
back during the tenure of treasurer bill
dwyer
and we have cons continued it with
current treasurer monica mezapelli
and in many many states
the public deposit investment pool does
fall within the jurisdiction of the
state treasurer
that is for most people the logical
place to put it
we're not looking to make more work for
anybody
um or to push this off onto anybody that
doesn't want it and so we're having
a conversation treasurer mitzi pelle has
been involved in it just as treasurer of
dwyer was
to find the most reasonable
place to put this i think people very
easily see the conflict of interest that
is created by
hosting the public deposit investment
pool within the banking department
um we're just looking to try to have
everybody on board for where this goes i
don't want to try to create any
controversy or difficulty for anybody in
the process of moving this on we'll
continue doing it
we're simply asking that we'd be able to
collect our expenses at this point in
time but i do
i think that's very um intuitive of you
uh representative walls that that's
where most states put it is is either
within or
or as a responsibility of the state
treasurer
do you have a follow-up representative
walls i do follow a please so the
implication of your answer is is that
many states put it in treasury
but apparently our treasurer doesn't
want it so there's a proposal to create
this independent commission rather than
put it with the treasurer because the
treasurer doesn't want this
am i hearing this correctly well i
wouldn't i wouldn't speak for treasurer
mezzapelli
or treasurer dwyer she'll be next you
could ask her then
before but i think that um
many other states don't some states
don't put it with their treasure
some some have created a separate
non-profit organization
or this type of a commission where um
the treasurer and a representative of
the bank department will sit on the
board so that there is still
some involvement of those entities
but it's not under their responsibility
so but i i don't want to speak for
treasurer matsapeli
i think everybody's extremely busy these
days and nobody's looking forward to
more work is
probably the answer representative
emerick you have a question
thank you madam chair my understanding
that when you get to the end of the year
and you're trying to even up
and you send out the bills they don't
get billed
they don't pay anything at all it's not
even at not even from the beginning of
the year so they never they don't
they're not included in the assessment
at the end of the year uh we perform
functions for and have for many years
perform functions for the public deposit
investment pool
around the calendar year long
but never collect a penny for for that
work which means that all of the
entities that we do
charge for ultimately end up um
subsidizing the operation of the public
deposit investment
what it would seem as a follow-up
follow-up it would seem as a minimum
they should be
receiving part of the allocation of your
uncovered
costs i mean at a minimum
uh thank you for the question i
understand i think that there's a
sensitivity to
the fact that the funds that we're
talking about here are taxpayer monies
and that we really would like to see
the maximum amount maximum return
possible returned
to the cities and towns and school
districts that
that placed their money with the public
deposit investment pool
by example i will tell you that pfm the
companies that we contract with to do
the administration of the public deposit
poll
does a very good job in my opinion
of managing the funds and being
extremely responsible and responsive to
the concerns of
governmental units in the in the state
of new hampshire
they have written in the contract that
they
signed with us the ability for them to
waive
their management fees and right now
in the last quarter they have been
managed waiving a percentage
of their management fees that they're
they are legally
allowed to charge to the pool because
they want to make
because interest rates are so low and
it's kind of hard to generate
some return to nothing about saying
nothing about
an attractive return that they're
willing to cut their fees
to keep the return to the cities and
towns
somewhat responsible but also
competitive they have an interest in
keeping the pool
at a at a reasonable size as i mentioned
it's normally about a quarter of a
billion dollars it's drifted down a
little bit
lately um and so um
they're very responsibly saying we'd
rather take a little bit of a haircut on
our fees
than lose participation in the pool i am
sensitive
to the fact that if we're not coming
along saying and we'd like to be able to
collect our
exact expenses we're not looking for
anything more
uh to make any money off the pool just
to recover our expenses
pfm is doing what everything they can to
maintain competitive standing of the
pool we think we should
join them in that so
jerry if i can just kind of summarize
where we are
you're you've had ongoing discussions
you continue to have ongoing discussions
you've looked at what
other states do but i believe you are
correct that kind of a policy change
requires a bill to be fired so what you
are proposing
is a small one paragraph change
that allows your agency
to recoup its expenses only its expenses
not make any money and not charge
the people that would be in competition
so this kind of evens a playing field
for everybody do i have that correctly
perfectly stated madam chair all right
are there any questions on
the commissioner's budget which does
start on page 325.
as he said it is lower than what they
wanted they have five unfunded positions
they spend zero general fund dollars
you're all completely self-funded
so we normally wouldn't once the
governor is done with you
we normally if you're happy we're happy
kind of thing
but any questions on the budget
represent walls yes madam chair
i i'd actually like to return for one
moment i have uh two quick questions on
the fund that the
commissioner is just talking about one
is he's not talking about a fund
representative walls he's talking
about invoicing this group for the
expenses that they pay
there is no fund involved well i'm
perhaps i
my choice of words is not as precise as
it should be
but i still have a question and one is
um the first one is
are there policies to um how much risk
can be made in the investments and the
second question is
have you looked at the cost of the
overhead okay one question at a time
let's let me
ask answer that one okay she asked about
risks
yes there are policies um that are
presented by pfm
to the commissioner and the public
deposit investment pool
for review and approval relative to the
maximum amount of risk and the types of
investments
that may be used by the public deposit
investment pool there is absolutely a
written policy
that we observe thank you follow up
uh the second question is a different
topic and that is the proposal you've
got here in roman five
of charging the agencies have you looked
at the cost
of the overhead of administering
administrating
administering that versus um the amount
that you'll collect or the benefit of
the collection
it's just cost benefit that's all i'm
asking
right have we looked at essentially have
i
guesstimated what the dollar amount will
be
that we will build the public deposit
investment pool
is that true have you looked at the cost
if you're going to start billing them
it's going to cost you money to bill
them you're going to have to have
somebody take time to do that
and the cost of having one person or
multiple people
put together those bills to each agency
have you looked at
what that's going to cost you yes it
will be negligible
um we currently do track our staff time
so that we can create the bills that we
send out for examination so
the majority of our staff is already
billing their time
it's all part of and it's it's been
synchronized into
the state's timekeeping system for um
paying paying our staff for creating
paychecks so it's a system that we have
in place already we won't have to create
a new one
there are a few people that don't
currently
monitor their stat their
activity generally by the hour myself
and the deputy commissioner
included we are
two of the unclassified positions within
the department and so we are paid a
salary
but i can tell you that in the past year
due to some unique efforts that we've
been involved in
for me it was operating the gopher
office for five months and for
many of my staff it is now volunteering
at the covet call center
we're all tr we now all have the ability
to track our time by the hour so that we
can properly
allot it to the buckets that they will
be paid out of so
i appreciate the question thank you the
effort will be minimal for us to
be able to track our time and bill thank
you so much
seeing no additional questions do what
do you guys think about approving his
budget
representative emerick moves to approve
the
banking budget as presented
representative griffin
seconds the motion when the clerk is
ready he will call the roll on the
motion to approve the banking budget
if you're in favor please say aye if
you're opposed please say nay
chairman uber aye vice chairman emmerich
the clerk votes i representative griffin
aye representative leishman yes
representative hatch aye representative
waltz
yes unanimous madam chair
jerry thank you you have
made a great presentation this
proposal that you're asking for requires
an amendment i will ask lba to present
the amendment which is something the
division
will take up then when the paperwork is
complete
but we appreciate you coming we
appreciate you being here thank you
thank you madam chair thank you members
of the committee great to see you
thank you for the invitation to come in
in person because it's so nice to be
able to be back in the llb and
to see you all
thank you it's been very nice thank you
thank you
we've got one minute
um
yeah you're live turn it off
but you're still live
should he speak to i guess that's the
real question
okay guys can we um move on
jerry thank you appreciate you being
here in person
i have moved
monica mezzapelli monica can you hear us
and can you
speak now that you're part of the panel
oh there she is great to see you
good morning um thank you madam chair
we appreciate you participating this
morning
chairman little just is still in the
room but he is
done and so we're here to talk about
your budget
um i'm going to turn it over to you
welcome thank you thank you again and
thanks for the opportunity to
participate remotely um i would
love to be there today um just um
different circumstances um
is keeping me home right now so um
so yes so um again for the for the
record
um state treasurer monica masapeli and
um what i would like to do today is um
um
first my objectives will be to to
provide an overview of
our our budget and the structure of the
treasury
uh highlight a few of the changes um
that are included in house bill 1 and
hospital 2
and hopefully leave some time for some
questions
and so i i was i was hoping to share my
screen i'm not sure if i'm going to be
able to do that just so we can
look at the the spreadsheet that i
provided
anything you provided to us has been
placed on
the lba website people can bring it up
who are listening
so you don't have to worry about sharing
your screen we have technology
the people in the room do not have
computers so they got
a hard copy this morning when they got
here but everybody else has an
electronic copy
perfect thank you so then again i will i
will just um
um i will sort of go uh over the
narrative that i have the
line and also look at the numbers at the
same time um so hopefully you can follow
me
so so first i will start with the uh the
structure of the treasury
we have 23 positions uh 12 positions are
in the division of treasury operations
and 10 positions in the abandoned
property division
we have um three uh four vacant
positions right now
or hope that now we're able to to fill
positions that or hope is to
to try to uh fill those vacancies uh so
we can operate more effectively
uh and and i meant to mention the uh
there is one position that is part of
the governor's scholarship program
that came to us uh in the last biennium
so moving on to the um to the actual uh
structure of our budget
uh our corporations are are about two
percent of the entire budget
uh which includes our treasury
operations and the division of vandal
property
the rest of the rest of our budget is
really um
just items are pretty much out of our
control
and so but um but obviously i will i
will go over that and
the um this the largest
portion of our budget it is uh debt
service so that represents approximately
50 percent of treasury's budget
the um the debt service
funded uh with general fund and
projects related to usnh that is
approximately 45 of our budget and in
this biennium we are
um we are estimating that we will issue
approximately 60 million in bonds
um funded with general funds each year
in approximately 10 million for usnh
projects so one thing that is different
uh in house bill 2
is we created a or or a new accounting
unit was created to
start accounting for that service
related to
the proposed unified university system
of new hampshire so
we want to keep track of that that
service
the existing that service and the new
debt server separately
so if this new entity is created
or merged what we want to do is be able
to track that debt service and one
accounting unit
so that will be projects related to the
community college
in the university system
um i don't i don't want to cover every
aspect of our debt service we do have
um school building aid and
existing that service for community
college
but what i would like to mention is um
what is what you're not gonna see here
is um
i'll project the lapses um that
are were that are gonna be generated as
a result of a bond refund
that we did in december of last year
uh we were able to um
we had two two bond refunds and we were
able to generate uh
present value savings of approximately
11.4 million
and so that is about 10 million over a
period of 10 years so the way this
refunding was structured
is that we're going to be able to
utilize the savings
during the first two years so in fiscal
year 21 we want to apply
uh where we're projected to apply 2.1
million in savings
and in fiscal year 22 um
we expect to apply 8.6 million in
service and and
and that um 8.6 million in
savings sorry about that so that is not
included in this budget that was
information that
um came after our numbers put together
but
that like any other labs will lapse at
the end of the biennium
the the next uh large piece of our
budget is
distributions to municipalities um
we budgeted or in our budget two items
are included the meals and rooms
distributions to municipalities
and also the revenue sharing that is
included in rsa 31a we
budgeted according to the law and during
the agency
budget the governor for the first time
is proposing to fund the entire
calculation of the meals and rooms
distribution and in the in prior years
that was capped to
68.8 million this year were included in
both years first year 22 and 23.
the the maximum amount that we could pay
to the municipalities related to this um
the meals and rooms distribution what
page is that on in your budget
and which um au and class line will we
find it
i don't have the budget in front of me
but
if you have the spreadsheet that i that
i probably
look at our budget books madame
treasurer
um or i don't have the button from me so
i will have to find that for you
represent griffin thinks it might be at
the bottom of page 169 in your budget i
don't know if you have a staff member
close who can help you
governor's authorized budget is on page
169 you're correct
my apologies should i continue or um
yes you should continue but i i hope
you'll bring your budget up so you can
see it because we are going to have
questions about your budget so we're
kind of waiting to make sure you got it
up
okay okay great great thank you for for
letting me know i will definitely pull
it right now
uh
nancy is your hand up for a reason or no
no no sorry madam chair
just trying to make sure people who want
to talk have a chance
okay so when you get your budget up you
may certainly continue
okay i'm ready okay great
so please continue thank you i apologize
about that
um
so um so house bill 2 is um
is again proposing the suspension of the
revenue sharing
and that is budget that was budgeted
at 25.2 million annually
um but again house bill 2 is proposing
um to not budget that this year
in the cabin and upcoming biennium
so now i want to move on to the unique
program
and um
this is a program that is
as administered by the college tuition
savings plan advisor commission
this this is a program that administers
two
two scholarships two scholarships that
provides grants to new hampshire
students
um house bill 2
is proposing a change in this program
and
this this this scholarships are funded
with
um an administrative assessment that is
um
that is charged to fighting and
participants so that's that's what
currently funds
uh these two scholarships so what's the
section in hb2 that
applies to unique please yes so that
section
in hospital 2s starts in section 160.
it goes to 160 through 168
that is changing the um language related
to the
um new hampshire excellence in higher
education trust fund
and what house bill 2 is proposing is to
distribute this funding differently it
will send
60 of these funds to a newly created
student loan relief program that uh will
be administered by the
business finance authority and
the other pers the rest of the 40
remainder
remaining will fund the scholarship
programs the existing
scholarship programs
um the only reason so in house bill 2
nothing changed
and demand this this this is abundant
and you will find that
um on the unique program
it is it is
we budgeted 15.9 million fiscal year 22
and 15.9 million and fiscal is 23
and nothing is changing there
um everything will remain the same the
only thing that will
that will change is the way um that line
item the grants and scholarships
scholarships line will distribute the
funding
so it would it will um
again we will pay um that percentage to
the
business finance authority for the
administration of the new program
and we will keep the other 40 percent to
pay for the administration of the two
scholarship
programs where do we find that dollar
those dollars in your budget what page
number and what account number
the account number is
1047 and
and you will find it on page 97 of the
budget
house by one
and so the reason i mentioned that is
because you're not probably not going to
hear from anybody else
about this this is this program's our
house and the treasury
and um again that's the reason i'm
mentioning that
so i would like to page 97 in the budget
is d.a.s
so i'm looking at the page of of the
actual budget so
if your medicare
it is on page 175 of the governor's
budget your budget book
unique program
i'm sorry we work off the governor's
budget monika we're in the governor's
budget
that's all we have we don't have
individual pages so we have to work
with these so uh nancy has said that's
on page
175 correct okay
that's the unique program
and page 174 is the governor's
scholarship fund
under the unique program madam chair
this is mike hoffman
um if i can interrupt for a second sure
monica just emailed you a copy of the
budget that the committee members are
looking at
the governor's recommended budget so
it's a pdf it should arrive in a second
there
it'll help us all be looking at apples
instead of
oranges and apples thank you i apologize
about that yeah representation while
we're sure he's waiting for the email to
come in
uh thanks man of chairs so before we get
too far from house bill 2 is there any
reason the
college tuition advisory
name is now being changed to just simply
scholarship commission and the advisory
has been
being removed from that
i am not familiar with the changes that
were proposed
in this in this budget um
i was only informed that um
there was going to be this new proposal
this new program
um but but the la the language uh being
recommended i
i am not familiar with um the details
related to that
uh thanks thanks madam chair okay we
probably
aren't going to be able to approve
anything until we find out who's
responsible because we're not
grandma strong okay please continue did
you get the email
i did okay great
and it's page 173 i just want to make
sure i'm on the
on the same page the unique program is
on page 173 and that's where it starts
very good
okay please continue
so i'll move on to um the governance
scholarship program
that was um that is um we included that
in our agency budget we included that in
under the prioritized needs
but in the governor's proposal um this
program has been funded again at the
same amount of three million
in this is uh general fund a general
funded program
um the other portions of the budget are
um the l-chip program that again is also
another pass-through grant or we just
house
the appropriation for this program and
the community development
block grant that's another amount that
is just being housed in our in our
budget
we simply uh distribute those funds yes
both of them come in and talk to us so
okay you're off the hook
the um the other piece i would like to
mention is our unrestricted
revenue related to abandoned property we
have um
we have budget and fiscal year 22 we
have budgeted
16.8 million and then fiscal year 23
18.4 million and that is um
really based on our 10-year projection
um
just because it's difficult to estimate
how much we're going to
actually receive and is cheat to the
general fund
but um but we believe we're going to be
um
you know close to this estimate um this
year we're not budgeting for
interest uh we don't anticipate any
interest um
to be recorded as revenue we hope to
generate interest to pay our bank
cost and that's due to the um
low interest rate environment that we're
in
and i guess um you know the last piece
that i i want to mention as part of this
presentation i was i was
asked to comment on the um contingent
limit
increase or or the additional um
debt guarantee that is being proposed in
house bill 2.
um what section is that and that is
since section 115
of house bill 2.
and um so husband stu is proposing this
increase
of 100 million for for manufacturing or
industrial projects in the biotechnology
sector
and it's also increasing the unified
contingent
limit um by 35 million
and um the question that was posted to
me is this will have any effect or
impact on the general fund
and um what i will say is um
this increase won't uh impact the
general fund directly
what um what we do with guaranteed debt
um debt to the state guarantees
we we include that debt and we consider
that as part of our overall debt and the
potential
of the state assuming that liabilities
so we include that in our debt
affordability study that we prepare
every year
and for the most part the to guarantee
that does not impact
um our debt to revenue ratios that we
use to
essentially measure our offer
our data affordability by increasing
um the limit by essentially 135 million
by itself it wouldn't impact our crew
rating
or our ability to to to issue more bonds
or that
be by itself but if the state
would ever um have to assume that debt
because because of the bonds were
defaulted the loans were defaulted
then at that point the state will have
to issue that amount
and and that would be probably the time
when um
the rating agencies will pay attention
to that um
even the consideration of having to
assume that debt
would probably trigger um a credit
um action that would that could
potentially
impact the state negatively but again
by itself increasing the limit
um wouldn't impact the state it's just
that possibility of
issuing that debt that will do something
that could
um impact natively the state
so with that um i think i cover
everything that i wanted to cover today
i will be happy to answer any questions
on on anything um that was yellow
division members have any questions
apparently not although usually as soon
as i say apparently not somebody says no
i thought of one but
i don't see any questions thank you very
much for being with us this morning we
appreciate it
and we are going to it's about
seven minutes before twelve we are going
to take a lunch break until one o'clock
at one o'clock we're going to go over
the
hp2 sections related to oplc
we heard their budget presentation in
detail
and although lindsey courtney spoke
about the
sections in hp2 at that time we only had
the draft copy
so we need to review those to make sure
that they're
what they were and we also have a
section
about uh workers comm
i don't know if it's workers training
labor's got something in there about
training ken merrifield talked about it
but again we didn't have
final copy of hb2 at that time so
between 1 and 130
we will talk about those sections
and otherwise we are going to be in
recess until one o'clock mike and nancy
are you going to
stop the zoom meeting as you did last
time when we took a lunch break
yes we'll we'll stop the meeting and
we'll restart
at one o'clock great see you all at one
o'clock
thank you very much for the hard work
this morning enjoy your lunch
thank you everyone